本人すか？
本人来ました
Twitterやっぱり使ってますよね？
使ってますね
下ネタがいえないくらいの数字になってますよね
言えねえぞホント
おわりだぜ？
twiterを使うと思うんですけど
実は、Twiterすごい機能があるんですよ
昔のツイートを見ることが出来るらしいんですよ
まじか
登録日はいつですか？
え、ちょっとね だいぶ古いんだよね
登録日が2012年の2月だから
もう5年間ぐらいか
5年間使ってるってことですね
5年もtwiterやってるの？
やばい やばい やばい
5年分の歴史あるわけじゃないすか
ありますね
そのー5年分の歴史をさかのぼる事が出来るんすよ
普通だと見れないんですか
普通だとこのTwiter上だと見ることはできないんですよ
なんか 限度が あるわけ？
限度があります
当初自分どんな事ツイートしてたんだろうみたいな
想像つきます？
その時って何歳だ？
18.19の時でしょ
もう 無理 無理 無理 無理 無理
絶対 無理
いろんな黒歴史がでてくるんじゃないか
やばい5やばいやばい
マジで多分気持ち悪いよ
ホントにマジで
今はさ大人になったじゃらさ
言葉がかっこいいじゃん
偏頭痛がくるとかさ
今は24なんで
結構さまともな事言えるようになったんですけど
そうでもねえや
今日はねそれをねあらい探ってってやろうと
なるほど、僕の過去を見ていこうというわけですね
という事でやっていきましょう
いや〜 やばかった 気がするな結構
これ。
これに打てばいいの？
これで作成した日で
いつから
2012年の6月くらいにしとこう
2012年の自分を探りましょう
これを自分のTwiterに貼れば
はじめしゃちょーのいつからいつまで みたいな
検索します
わ、 やばいやばいやばいやばいやばい 無理 無理 無理 無理
でもこれはほかのひとのを見る事ができますよね
いけるね
だって パッと目に入ってきたのこれだよ
バイト終わったー！ 今日は6Lぐらいぶちまけて、店内オイルショック警報がでたぜー
ATフィールド全開 店長ごめんなさい
きもい きもいきもい
すごい バイトしてた時代ですよ
バイトしてたね
コンビニの油で作るやつ
油全部こぼしちゃって
やばい　やばい　やばい
ヒット＆アウェイ　キャッチ＆セールスって言ってる
ただの宣伝だと思う　チャンネルの
今日もコンビニバイト　俺
いらっしぃませ～
お客様、大きいレジ袋5枚くれ　俺
バイトに関するツイートが多いすね
そうだね
そうか、バイトにあけくれてたのか　その頃は
コンビニのバイトだけで月
12万とか13万
いってたときもあった
そうだ
マイペースイズ、ベスト
きもいよ
え～　ムリムリムリムリムリ　も～　ムリ
それはきもい　それはきもい
まって
ホントこの絵文字がきもいよね
帳消しするよさすがに
きもい　きもい　ホント　ムリムリムリムリ
卵を産むのは　ウブラブ
産まないのは
ファービです
ははははははははWWW
似て非なる存在です
これはセンスあるね　これはセンスあると思う
いいと思います　これは
副社長、洗濯ありがとう
うふっふふふふふふ
この当初からせんたく。。。
洗濯してもらってたんですね
5年前からクズじゃんもう
２０１２年11月26日
ほいほい
チャンネル登録者7777人だそうです
ォほ～～
1万人もいってない時か～
わ～じゃすごい若かった時だ
あれ財布どこいった？
今と変わらないじゃないすか
変わってないね
1時間前に同じこと言ってたんもんね
同じこといってました
いいこと言ってますね
アンチてっきり増えた
正直、つらいけど　俺は無視する
もう～～　ムリムリムリムリ
だれがなんと言おうとこれが俺のスタイル
しんどい　しんどい
このころつらかったんだろうね　多分
気にしちゃってた時期ここは
とげとげしてたんだこのころは
この動画で歴史を変える　はじめ社長
あほあほ
コアラのマーチ50箱まとめて買ってみると
これで歴史を変えようとしてたんだね～
はははははｈW
外でるの寒かったから限界まで厚着してみた
やばいよ　宣伝の仕方やばいよ
ウソ！　見るだけで歯肉炎が防げる
はははははははｈWW
とんでもねえ詐欺師だなこれ
きもいわ　これきもいわ
youtubeってなみんなとつなぐ管なんだせ
エヘヘ
あはははははｈ
あははははははははWW
ワイルド、はじちゃんだぜ～
寒いだろ～
まじしんどいよ～
よだれでた
おほほほほほほ
なりきるね
あ～～ははははははははWW
あ、やばい　やばい　やばい
5月なので5月からですね
任せた、最初のツイートなに？
ありましたね
どういうツイートだと思います？
最初のツイートでしょ
初めまして　みたいな
はじめまして　はじめしゃちょーですみたいな
なるほど
なに？
一番最初のツイートはこちらです
はい
歯にできるだけ歯間フロス入れてみました
はははははははWW
これが最初か
その時、YHOOO映像トッピングにのったら人気出るかなと思って
映像推薦っていうやつで自分の映像推薦してて
お～～～～
歯間フロス入れるだけの動画推薦してて
ははっはははｈWW
そっか、これから出してたのね～～
こっから始まってましたね　歴史はもう
おほほほほほ
ははははっははは
最近、顔変わったな～～
1200個分のゼラチンを使ってグミを作った
今もう　動画ないんだけど
はっははははははｈWW
肉眼で金環日食
泡吹いて倒れた
絶対、倒れてないじゃん
明日から2日間、ディズニーランドで研修うけてくるぜ～～
ローソンのトップクラスみたいなのに選ばれて
ディスニーランドで研修させられたんだよ
え、はははは
サービス業のプロって
接客はまじめにやってた結構
おまえらかかってこいよって言ってる
はははははははWW]
や～こんなもんかな
お～～～おおおお～～
1年で5万人いってるね
じゃあ、だいたい
でもすごい、2013年で5万人いってたのか～～
すごいっすね
まあ、だれにだって
黒い歴史って
あるんじゃないでしょうか
これぼくじゃなくて
他のみんなみれるでしょ？
見れますね
て、事はみれましたね
見れるな、これは
過去のツイートを全部見る方法が
FROMでだれかの名前いれて
SINCE　なになに
untll なになにで
いつから、いつまでか
見れます
ぜひみんな
いろんな人の黒い過去
見つけようぜ！
パ　ピ　プ　ぺ　ポ
パ　ピ　プ　ぺ